that's Gomez and welcome to three free
games with ports three free games it
sounds funny a lot of times I play games
and they're funny and they're they're
worth showing off but I just feel like
they have a little they just lack
substance to actually make a video out
of them but I still want to show them so
I figured why not pick three of them and
make a video animate because I want you
bros to feel like hey goodbye video it's
not just me him talking for five minutes
it has more than that
so I hope you appreciate it and let me
know what you think at the end of it
there we go
first game is moose diary what what was
it called again
super digestion Mia moose okay I don't
know anything about this game except
that it's worth checking out apparently
I am what the [ __ ] just happened what
the [ __ ] did I just do all right so I'm
a moose in Sweden most likely find a
carrot that I need to eat and by
clicking on it
of course everyone knows oh no nothing
okay I'm gonna get high Oh God diarrhea
good jokes yay confetti yay
thank you much thank you he's so carry
eat that Apple don't oh god diarrhea is
coming sorry mate
oh god more diarrhea everyone knows
moose it sounds like cows everyone also
knows that fruit and vegetables oh [ __ ]
me
just it just rains down on the from the
[ __ ] sky I need a shape up man
let's see if I can beat my incredibly
high high score of 3 this is literally a
Swedish simulator all we do is eat [ __ ]
[ __ ] how can I be so fat from fruit and
vegetable oh god diarrhea oh god I'm
sorry mate sorry mate god dammit so have
your ability to turn off the poop but
[ __ ] that I have to beat my 18 I just
have to [ __ ] me are you serious it's
really hard huh don't die don't die oh
god I'm sick what the final poop to
death all right just watch me I'm gonna
[ __ ]
it's so hard stop pooping just stop just
keep it in can't beat 18 for some
[ __ ] reason this is like the new
flappy bird I swear to god it's [ __ ]
pissing me off here we go come on you
little [ __ ] don't you dare shutdown me
you [ __ ] I will turn you into [ __ ] come
on yeah what you gonna do about dad I
wonder if we can meet Santa Claus in
this game
hang in there most purse our God is so
thin he's gonna explode into death and
sufferings but he's still happy Thank
You murse
thank you cute kid little a free game
check it out see if you get a higher
score than me second game is SMS drive I
think and check it out
welcome to Assam I started driving it's
a lot of that again that means it's
gonna be bad I mean good game drive the
car with vague hold shift to look at
your phone write text messages with the
mouse try to complete one lap around the
course Oh God so we are you oh my god is
it like yeah it takes to drive but
actually texting and driving holy [ __ ]
wow oh my [ __ ] god that is I wish I
could reply whatever the [ __ ] I wanted
this is literally Yolo the game wait am
i driving backwards Oh God Oh who's
texting me this [ __ ] who is that
important do I want to get laid that
badly oh this is the worst conversation
of all time wait where the [ __ ] am I
going
even in Mario Kart you get a [ __ ] nap
sir are you sorry oh my god seriously
seriously right now are you sir
Oh God Oh God
combine two incoming messages within ten
seconds but what if I have one too
[Music]
who-who-who expect a text in ten seconds
what the [ __ ] maybe I have better things
to do what if I get laid okay that's
probably not happening but I'm just
saying it's a power cut oh I'm doing
this to get like that it makes sense
what the [ __ ] why do you keep texting me
yellow page all right I got this is
[ __ ] in the bag if you know I'm saying
that sounded weird okay text me that you
[ __ ] okay
Yolo on the whole oh [ __ ] that didn't
sound good I just wish I knew where I
was going for [ __ ] sake okay it Oh
[ __ ] please
disclose Oh text me [ __ ] Oh M oh god G
what [ __ ] barbecue sauce on my naked
body don't text drink and dry breath I
mean don't ya that too but don't drink
in text don't text and drink that too
actually don't ok don't combine drinking
when anything but salad I was gonna say
sex but that'd be a pretty appropriate
yo no for the third time because why
text any oh god what the [ __ ] why text
anything else there we go
I think we're almost done see I Drive
shitty even without texting
and go outside or quit playing and go
outside [ __ ] that whoa MLG Sun oh [ __ ]
come on alright alright alright I got
this I got this we got this pretentious
I'm gonna do this super fast sanic speed
brothers sanic seed sanic seed that's
how he was born he's gonna nail this
curve [ __ ] this covers long okay Oh need
for speed casted as PewDiePie need for
peace I'm sending you an S so look at
that beautiful I don't get distracted we
ha [ __ ] set Yolo [ __ ] I gotta beat 173 I
gotta do it my god I got so much speed I
sure hope I don't get a text now [ __ ]
we're almost there can we be 10 seconds
can do we do it can we do it come on you
little [ __ ] I think you are an [ __ ]
would you like to try again oh no my
friend think I'm an [ __ ] so I was
talking to my friend are you
I got it are you serious all jokes aside
don't text and drive it can wait
you put other people's lives risk other
people lives at risk
it's inconsiderate and you should have
thought for your babies all right last
but not least we're gonna play a spooky
game it's called insanity Dec see it's
supposed to be sanic it should be
insanity it's fun made in this engine I
don't know what that is but that means
it's gonna be weird as [ __ ] alright oh
god that's [ __ ] loud what the [ __ ] oh
Jesus minecraft man
step down the volume a notch sorry
alright some tails flying in super space
looking for sanic my one and true only
love my hair is literally a duck great
fanfictions oh hello made with a creepy
game made with game maker wow thanks for
thanks for describing that for me what
is this
this teeth sewn together the story
begins with a really mean man his name
was dr. Ivo Robotnik he wanted in the
world oh [ __ ] that's fantastic
alright press Start alright here we are
where am I I don't know this place looks
familiar
the empty and dark I must find a way out
to you go sanic you gotta go so fast
sanic gotta go fast robot so you're
behind all this Eggman sanic dick
educate me this game from here it is
really famous keep the fast action to me
Eggman what keep fast action to me
Edmund I don't know what that means but
keep oh god oh god
keep fast action to me Eggman right
let's try that how do I jump there we go
alright go sanic oh Jesus go sanic go
you're a ho go face
well Slender Man what are you doing oh
my god minecraft I go this way see what
happens
[Music]
don't listen to Luigi Bros don't smoke
weed everyday' you can't run Oh God but
I am running like I'm totally running oh
god yeah kind and fair kind of an affair
now good not too perfect this game is
actually a social social critic
criticism too so now you know my true
identity to society
you're on my world now I am the hipper
mind never mind
again I'm curious what happens if you go
back nothing all right
oh god this is hard to look at my eyes
are just like Minecraft gotta go so face
gotta get all the balls rings I mean I
like to think that they're balls
oh my god having fun Puetz
how does he know I'm having fun
what the [ __ ] seriously what ah it hurts
so much I hope so I hope so I am having
fun I hope you're watching I just can't
stand it's [ __ ] noise alright let's
go down there and die
oh my god I'm playing as tails where am
I now that clone Eggman's my body to
some of that evil go tails go tails
you're too slow you're a hoe cuff what
what are you I can is sanic sanic is my
love I must find him I'm so gripped by
this story oh my god they don't have any
eyes chels wait oh that [ __ ] got served
I'm glad you get rid that insolent fool
friend let's just get out of this creepy
place shall we yeah right Oh hunt and
this is open in my browser and it's
downloading all the second stop I don't
want to download all the sanic games
thank you
No I said stop it what the hell all
right that was free free games
with pants I hope you enjoyed let me
know if you like this for me cuz I don't
know like I said a lot of times there's
games I want to play but they're just
too short or they don't have enough sub
sense and I just want to [ __ ] out videos
I want you boys to get a little bit more
of that juice if you know I'm saying how
to do I want to milk you
you know so that's all for me stay
awesome bros thank you for watching me
think of me like you're the best
I love you seriously bro